[Music]
[Music]
what a wonderful day to be in the house
of the lord if you're here with us for
the first time
please stand
what a beautiful family i'm glad you're
here
how's your daddy like that new farm
you're drawing things good doing things
right
yesterday
[Music]
[Music]
man
[Music]
wow
[Music]
we need to find water somewhere
and that soil ain't wet we're going to
lose the crops
[Music]
okay
are you pretty boy
pretty boy i'm not pretty i'm good
looking
hello everyone and welcome to the
academy's visiting artists film series
on minari a conversation with writer
director lee isak chong
my name is janet yang and i'm a governor
at the academy of motion pictures arts
and sciences in the producers branch
i am also an officer chairing its
membership committee and now i'd like to
introduce to you lee isaac tong hello
lee isaac
the last time i saw you was at the
nominees uh dinner for producers and
directors and we were very wise to bring
back those like you who were nominated
previously last year but didn't get a
chance to celebrate you in person
so that
was that was um i want to take you back
to that time because
one thing that's gone viral i think on
the internet is when you were informed
of your nomination and your adorable
daughter who was
fully prepared for the moment more so
perhaps than you what did it feel like
at the moment to to be honored in that
way
um that that was yeah that was
quite a strange time that was a year ago
um and we were juggling you know the
effects of the pandemic along with um
this incredible
awards run for the film so it was this
weird um
weird thing to be going through i think
that thing that with my daughter was the
golden globes that's that's
the golden globes yeah when when the
announcement for the oscars happened i
was honestly i slept because i thought
i don't want to like assume i'm going to
get nominated i'm not going to watch the
nominations
and then i woke up and found that i had
like hundreds and hundreds of texts and
that's that's when i realized something
happened
um so yeah it's it's just weird i never
get hundreds of texts
well you're probably getting more texts
now than you did before it you also had
been so celebrated at the sundance film
festival earlier in the year so you
probably got used to getting a lot of
attention and and you hadn't made a film
in a while so did you
have a feeling about that and how far
the film would be embraced so widely
no i i didn't um no i don't i'm not
getting used to the attention um
yeah it's it's weird because this one
was one in which a film in which i
probably was thinking the least about
like
would this get an award or would this do
well or
um you know i
maybe that's not true my first film i
was kind of like that and it was such a
pure process and then um i made two
films after that and
that kind of idea of
um getting some notice was was heavily
in my mind and um and those films didn't
turn out uh to do that for me so i had a
difficult go at it
for a few years and this film ended up
being um
almost like a swan song like i wondered
if i could even get it made it was it
was like maybe the last thing i would
ever write that's what i was thinking i
went off to teach i was also a professor
chung in korea so um
you know i i just went off and taught
and i thought maybe i'll never make a
film again
um and so when i was given a chance to
make this film
my whole idea with it was just to be as
personal as possible just to relish the
experience of making a film
um and just to
um go back to the purity of why it is we
tell stories like to love people to
to get into their stories to inspire
audiences you know all these different
things that i just think cinema when
it's clicking is so so wonderful and
amazing
um so
all the other stuff that's happened
since then honestly i wonder like if
it's real like
it's it's kind of unbelievable um but
but i'm just so touched that people
i think are responding to
the joy and purity with which we made
the film because i think we were all
trying to be very vulnerable with each
other and with the material
just so just to see people responding to
it has been
really really beautiful
do you think it's a sign of the changing
times because i
i am very encouraged as i think you are
about the attention that asians and
asian americans are getting on screen
and i like to think this is something
that is not going away that it's just
the tip of the iceberg and there's more
and more authentic voices that can be
embraced
um your film was a game changer others
in recent years have been as well i
think it's no surprise you know crazy
rich asians or parasite or drive my car
but yours it was was such an intimate
film
and precisely because it seemed so
deeply felt and personal
i i think people
widely loved it
whether or not you could relate to this
particular family
do you do you see that as as
as being a a sign of what is happening
now
um i mean i i appreciate that um i do
see a lot of reasons to hope um i think
joy luck club did very well when it came
out
i kind of feel like
it it's an issue in which it's not just
that um audiences are embracing films
like this but it's that i think
we're being given more opportunities now
and i think when when filmmakers of
various backgrounds are able to have
those opportunities what we see is that
um
that audiences actually want to see
those films and i think joy luck club
proved that and a lot of these films
that are coming out these days are kind
of proving that as well which has been
really wonderful like that's one of the
great things about all the platforms we
have to watch films is that it's it's
truly made things a lot more diverse
yeah
well your film was um
just a joy to watch
the pain and the depth the heart
um one of the things that does make it
unusual is it doesn't fall into any
tropes whatsoever because we we have for
instance on tv now there's three
different shows about asian americans
who do martial arts and more power to
them but yours was something that took
place outside of an asian community in
the heart of the midwest
and uh do you think that added to the
relatability of it it is obviously
related to a personal story
but
we're just you know
um
how
you probably have had some time to think
about
why this film has been just so beloved
and do you think that's one of the
reasons
um well you know i i didn't go into this
one thinking about whether it's
marketable or not um i
and
i i wonder if there are some stories
that get made because that kind of gets
put in front of the cart in a way that's
that's the horse that's put in front of
the cart
um
for me this was just a very personal
story and it comes from the way that i
grew up and um
[Music]
i i wasn't putting the issues first in a
way i was putting more um
the emotions and the the spiritual
dynamics um of the story first like the
the idea of love within this family a
family really trying hard to love each
other and having a hard time at it
um
and i think that's what it seems people
are responding to with it and i
recognize that
in a lot of films that i watch
it's
it's always um it's always the human
qualities of the films that seem to
resonate with me it doesn't matter where
those films are from
um for instance i i loved uh
worst person in the world you know of
this past year and drive my car and
these are very
you know films from other cultures but i
still
really felt like i was
connecting very deeply with the
filmmakers
um
so i kind of hope that's
that's what it was with this one it's
really hard to
take this as a case study for me
even moving forward and to figure out
like how do i how do i reach an audience
again it's just
yeah
i think you do it with with your heart
like you did with this but um that you
know several of the characters in your
movie are again surprises i i appreciate
it because i've seen just about
everything there is to say about you
know representations of asians and asian
americans on screen but the grandmother
character uh yun yu jung who
gave that fabulous oscar speech last
year she also is not at all your typical
she's feisty
she's not this kind of long
grandmother that's sacrificing
everything she has her own life she has
a you know a troubled relationship
initially with her grandson
how did you shape this character is she
someone in your life
yeah i think with uh you know i i
before you came on jan i was mentioning
just how fictional these characters are
um but in this case
um
i gotta say i i don't know what a quote
unquote typical grandmother is because
um i was partly raised by my grandma who
came from korea and she was
um
she drove me nuts she drove she drove me
and my sister nuts she uh
she
loved to you know annoy us and and do
these things that would just set us off
and
um and at the same time she was
tremendously loving and she was really a
best friend uh for me growing up um and
she just wasn't uh
i don't know she wasn't
um
you know doing doing the sorts of things
that you might you might expect a
grandmother to be doing
she didn't seem i guess like a lot of
the grandmothers who i met around me in
in lincoln arkansas
so it was always hard to describe to
people what my grandma's like
and sadly it seemed like
nobody else kind of knew her because she
couldn't speak the language
she spent most of her time with us
um so a lot of people just didn't see
her and
that's that was one of the elements of
this film that i wanted to do was to was
to kind of reveal
this person who i felt was invisible
trying to make someone like that visible
and what about your
other casting choices it just was like a
perfectly assembled family what were the
challenges and who did you have in mind
uh early on or who came late to the to
the team
yeah um so when i'm
writing usually i don't have anybody in
mind it's uh i had will patton in mind
for paul that was the only person i had
in mind as i wrote
um
and
um i think stephen came on first
and
that was because we we already kind of
knew each other he's married to my
cousin
my first cousin who grew up in arkansas
so we we kind of knew each other
but we also started to be represented by
the same agent around the same time
and she kind of connected us both
knowing this project saying hey you guys
should work together on this and i i was
i was really scared i didn't want to
mess up a family relationship and i
um i wasn't sure if you'd want to do
this because you'd have to speak with an
accent the whole time as well and and
you know how charged that can be that
that sort of issue
for asian actors
um so i was i was really pleasantly
surprised when we connected and he
he loved the script and wanted to do it
um
so he was the first uh yi family uh
person i had on my my family picture
frame that i was like building out as i
was prepping the film
and i i was able to fill in uh yuen
yojong and
um hanyedi next and i was living in
korea at the time so i was able to meet
them in person
and um
you know uh
yoon yojong was just a dream to work
with and
i
i just jumped at the chance that if if
if she could do it i would work with her
um so if mutual friend of ours put us in
touch and we met together
i think she was only interested in
whether or not this story was real
that's what she she asked like is is
this a real story yes i'll do it that
was that was kind of it oh yeah and you
told her it was a real story i i did i
mean i
kind of told her how it was written yeah
and then
um also grew up on a farm in korea so we
had that
um
there was a similarity there so when we
got together we didn't talk
much like we were pretty quiet with each
other but there was just a shared
comfort and i kind of felt like we we
understood each other
um so that's how they came about
to be like those those three got
involved in the project and then the big
challenge to answer your question was
finding the kids that was that was
really tough um
we had maybe two months to find them and
um
uh we knew that they would be
most likely non-actors people have not
acted before and we had
this wonderful casting agent julia kim
just
scoured
korean churches and hagwons and
different places where kids
korean kids are congregating and we're
just looking for
a korean kid who'd be able to speak in
korean um pretty fluently
and
also can act and and all these other
things
um so it was it was just a miracle that
we found
both alan kim and and noel kate cho um
they're they were just incredible we
we had them get together on zoom kind of
like this and just talk to each other as
though they're brother and sister and we
saw them clicking
and noel was like asking him if he did
all his homework and you know she was
she was saying all these things that
i was just watching like a family
conversation happening um it was really
magical and then stephen
came in for allen's audition and
actually did some improv with alan and
um allen like sat on his lap and
um i just saw a dad and his son and i
thought wow this is going to be great so
that's how we ended up going with them
and that ellen kim he's a he's a
superstar he's a huge follower
you said about two or three things just
now that i wanted to follow up on
one is the importance i think of having
a say a casting breaker having an entire
crew for that matter
that really understands and can relate
to the story i mean i can't imagine
somebody
helping you with casting and not being
able to get into korean churches and
knowing where to go and have developing
a whole network
i assume that was something very
intentional on your part
um
uh yeah
there are many intentional choices with
our crew of
specific times when we needed somebody
who's bilingual who's korean who
understood the culture
um and julia was one of the
one of those as our casting director
um because she would have to be talking
to parents and
and she would understand the nuances of
exactly what we're looking for like
which generation
this child is like when did the parents
come over like all these things have
their own nuances
um and then the other was we we
definitely needed somebody who could
speak korean as an editor so harry yoon
who we
brought on board
it was just so great to work with him
and
i remember some producers came in
or
some people from the studio and we
showed them a cut
and we totally forgot that they don't
understand korea and we didn't subtitle
it
and we're saying oh yeah this doesn't
make sense for you guys because you know
we were just able to edit it in korean
and english with that sort of
shorthand between us so so there were
key moments where we just felt like we
needed to
cut to the chase with that stuff just
because we didn't have a lot of time and
um it would just help the flow of making
the film
well i i am uh again
pointing out how wonderful it is to be
working in this day and age where there
are enough people to choose from when we
were making the joy luck club we
definitely could not find an asian asian
american casting director
we had a few other
roles for asians but very very very few
they just didn't exist at the time so
it's it's wonderful that
we can
crew up and cast up in the ways that
we'd like
i had another question about why you
were living in korea at the time and was
it related to this film because
this obviously took you back to some
very deep roots
and you know how did your time in korea
affect the making of the film or vice
versa
um
[Music]
so i went to korea to start teaching i
got a job offer to teach
as i was writing minari
in
2018 and so it was a chance to
finally have some kind of stability uh
financially in in terms of um my own
work
and uh my wife had carried the load for
for us and um
especially because i had asked for like
a couple years for me to try to write
something um
and so it was my my time to you know
kind of i gave up my two years let's
let's go ahead and move and
um going over there what was incredible
was
one like i got to live out my own
immigration experience of what that's
like to go to a place i'd never lived
and my wife you know doesn't speak
korean she's she's hong kong chinese
um so
we were going there with our daughter so
we kind of were immigrants it was very
different from the way my parents
immigrated of course a lot more
luxurious
for us but the other thing is we were
placed in um
where i was teaching was in this place
called
and it's um in this area with a lot of
mud flats
off the coast of incheon
and that's on the the western side
um
and what i found out from my mom was
that that's actually where my
grandmother who i wrote um the character
immunity after
um took my mom for about two years after
she became a widow so so my my
grandfather died in the korean war as a
soldier and my my grandmother took my
mom there and she would gather shellfish
in the mud flats and that's how she
would like feed my mom and my mom hates
shellfish to this day by the way she
because she ate so much of it but i had
no idea that she did that and in my
office i could look out and i could see
people women
mostly women going out and gathering
these shellfish and it's a hard living
um so it was strange for me to be there
um to think like oh my grandma did that
so i can be here
um in this building you know in the air
conditioning and doing something that
you know so so much um better than what
she had to go through
um so i just felt a closeness to her and
um that that really
gave me a type of compass as i was
making this film hmm
well it's uh very apparent that some
deep connections were made then and
and um
having gone on that personal journey
also is
quite remarkable
um
the other thing you said earlier was uh
being a little bit nervous about asking
steven to
to speak with an accent
do you feel like we've come a ways away
now that we have
much more uh many more projects and
filmmakers and talent that are
resurfacing
do you feel that it is now
much easier
to
make a film like minari and not be
nervous about that because we've gotten
over the extreme sensitivity that
existed when we had so few opportunities
yeah um i mean i
i kind of go both ways on it i i do feel
like there are reasons to be optimistic
and hopeful
um i still think it's a little hard um
because
you know i think i think before us the
farewell was um
being listed often as as one of the
first you know to have so much chinese
language dialogue
in the film and in many ways they paved
the way like we often use the farewell
as an example for why we can get away
with using a lot of korean dialogue
because um
to be honest there were hard discussions
that were
that in which there were people who were
worried about us using so much korean
in our film
and i think that it also limited our
budget like the fact that we were like
you know shooting this film for under 2
million um that that was reflective of
the
the type of film that we were making
because it was not english language
um and then you signed the release of of
this film um just that level of
confusion about um is this an american
film is this a foreign film
um
so
my my thought on it now is like i hope
you know what lulu did was incredible
with the farewell
um and that entire team i hope that our
team as the midnight team that we also
helped make it easier for people
in in what they want to do
to tell the story that they want to tell
to prove that hey um you know that there
is an audience for stuff like this
and also that um you can create roles
that
are you know all different types of
roles for actors and that um
you know they can be very complex and
and interesting
um yeah i don't know if that answers the
question no it it it does it does it's
just interesting to see how far we've
come and things are changing there's
still a lot of anti-asian hate crimes
and you know so there's in my mind good
news bad news every day really good news
and really bad news there's it's it's
not a straight line uh whatsoever
but you know we do we can and this film
really uh for for many people i think
was just another giant leap forward i
mean let's face it koreans are killing
it these days
between uh squid game and
pachinko's is is another beloved series
and so just you know again as bang duho
famously said that one inch of subtitles
we can get over that obstacle so much
more is available to us
absolutely
and and it means a lot i think for our
children and our grandchildren
what does your child make of of this
movie have you watched with her and also
your wife and did they learn a lot
about you and your
personal
excuse me
while you were
making this and you know how did it
change uh
conversations you had in your own family
um
[Music]
i i i do feel like it it brought out
working on this broad out a lot from
like my wife knows me very very well um
we have a very open relationship with
each other
um and i i think what it helped me with
was that i remembered a lot more and i
was able to contextualize things in my
own mind about my childhood as well
um
um
for for instance like i i've always kind
of like downplayed like certain things
in my childhood
or just not mentioned it but then
i i was able to say to her like you know
i think my childhood was kind of tough i
had some tough
tough times like half our farm
burned down you know and and we just
kept going and
um
you know it's stuff that now i can
contextualize and think about my actual
story of things that i've lived through
and i can kind of say to her okay i
think i have
these anxieties because i
because of this and um so it was nice to
work on it
in the sense that i um learned more
about myself with certain things
um for my daughter she just kind of grew
up uh with me making this film because i
was writing it when she was like four or
five and
and she came to set
um and
she got to see the baby chickens and all
that stuff and
and then she got to see like this awards
run
she seems immensely proud of of what's
going on
and
um yeah it's just been fun to share this
with her to be able to do the work
with my family and not in spite of them
like somehow to to be together with them
like they came to tulsa and and all the
award stuff i was at home i was doing
these zoom calls for all that award
stuff so
i'd have an interview with hollywood
reporter then i'd
come out of the room and they're sitting
there and i'm you know
i'm like trying to shake off my nerves
and all that stuff with them so you know
we were together for all of it which
which was really great and so i was
wondering if there's something you
wanted to share with this audience about
how you
deal with your emotions and and
the mining of them
for your
work um
yeah it's it's
i i
there's a part in the film where um
jacob says
jacob's yelling and he's having a fight
and he says i've been at this for 10
years and he like bangs the table
and
um
that came out of
me writing at the coffee shop where i
was going every day and i'm banging that
into the dialogue i've been at this for
10 years you know that kind of
thing um
and
um
yeah it's strange when i was in korea um
i thought i thought this i i sometimes
tell this story i thought this film was
not going to get made like we got right
to the finish line
and
because of everybody's schedules i was
told
that look if we don't
get this all figured out in the next
week this film is not gonna happen and
if it doesn't happen in this next week
then
probably it'll never happen because
this actor has to do this this actor has
to do that and then by then it's like
maybe five years from now we'll make the
film you know that's kind of what i was
told and i knew the writing
i mean that reality meant okay this film
is gonna die
um
and
um something weird happened was that i i
just hung out with my wife and daughter
that weekend and
um
i just felt
deeply at peace and deeply grateful for
them in this way that it just washed
over me like this this feeling of
thanksgiving and peace
um
on on a very spiritual level i'd say and
like i just felt like i have no
feeling of regrets in life i can move on
now
like i realize i've come i i came this
close to it it would have been nice but
i have everything i need
um and once once i had that
feeling like i just really said i really
said goodbye to filmmaking
and then the next week it it happened
like we got we got the green light
everything fell into place
um it was late but but it just
like i needed to go through that
experience somehow on this cosmic level
i think
and i carried that into this film
because i felt like that's what jacob
goes through
um and i've i've been carrying that with
me since then this this feeling of an
anchor of what it is that kind of
grounds me in this work
and that's why i i feel like i don't
get too anxious nowadays with it
um
but
the the truth is like the fears are
always there for us in this industry as
you know janet like even after success
what you start to hear is
you only have three years to make a film
and
um you know otherwise people are going
to start forgetting you um you know i've
been hearing messages like that quite a
lot and
um i don't have anything that looks like
it's going to go soon right now and you
know there are a lot of reasons why
maybe i should be worried but um
yeah it i
i don't know that that's kind of the
anchor that i've been having and i hope
that offers something for people i'm
sure it does because what i often feel
and try to talk about is the spiritual
challenges because on the one hand what
you did in that moment with your family
was to let go right let go of something
you were yearning for it brings tears to
my eyes to talk about actually
but you you know you wanted so
desperately to do something
and in the end you have to let go
because you're not in control and and
sometimes just by the letting go
things happen you know right and uh yet
you you have to maintain a certain
amount of faith and belief in yourself
to keep going so it's really asking very
dirt you know the the journey asks of
very different things from you you know
both to be thoroughly committed and then
be able to detach at a certain
point so it's a it's a it's a rather you
know it's like an accordion you have to
expand and contract with the with the
circumstances
but um
yeah and i think that seeking out
um success in this
work in film in this industry in order
to solve some deep issue i i think that
that's only going to disappoint like
even if you find success like i
honestly feel like that's that's not
going to be it so um
well certainly if one is chasing fame or
fortune or celebrated them
that there is
zero guarantee of that you know at most
we
we can achieve something that we want to
put out in the world that we believe
strongly and and hopefully connects with
the audience is how i see it you know
it's the the external
success factors are simply beyond our
control yeah and and it works both ways
things that
seemingly are going to be wildly
successful and are not or seemingly and
as in the case of miyanati very personal
film
that broke a lot of rules becomes a huge
quote-unquote success in that it just
touched people and that that gives me
hope is that sometimes the purity
of that reaction from others you know is
what carries the day and
that's why you know many people just
are still talking about meenati and
as far as i'm concerned you can take the
rest of your life to make whatever you
want to make there is no pressure
do not feel any pressure it's not it's
not just three years
um i i believe some students have
questions so i'm going to take some
questions from them
are there questions if not i have i have
more questions so if there are oh i see
a lot of hands raised okay
um justin park
hello
um my question is that
it's very interesting to look at minari
in respect to the first film that you've
made um
i'm not going to attempt to
say the title but the one that was said
in rwanda
the sense that it's that is where you
are almost kind of there as an outsider
kind of looking into their stories and
trying to their stories to the world
where minari is kind of like the almost
the opposite where
the story coming from internally from
your own personal history
so
which is why
what you said about noting down visual
memory was so interesting to me because
it's
i'm guessing even the rwanda film
you may have not experienced what they
have experienced and what they live
through in contemporary ronda kind of
the situation there but the visual
memory from the film i'm guessing is
still true to you at during your time
you spend there so could you kind of
discuss a little more about how you how
you have navigated
a different story
that you've told so far as filmmaker and
how how
you
think you will continue to
work on that navigation do you see it as
it's kind of like an
insider outsider kind of type deal or is
there a more kind of a unifying factor
that you have to your
perspective yeah thanks justin thank you
for
knowing about that first film even
um
that that film was so fun to make we
i i went to rwanda i had about like a
nine page outline of the story and while
i was there um that outline was kind of
based on something i had read as i was
researching the country
but when i got there i just started to
really work with people and interview
people and
almost like a communal
in a communal
sort of sense we just shaped together
the story we started adding
different people's memories so there was
that similar element to this where
um a couple of the actors like their
actual
stories um the two leads in that that
film
um they would tell me things that
they've lived through and then we would
incorporate them into the film so we
kind of did some of that stuff with that
film
um
but yeah i felt very comfortable
in rwanda as an outsider in some sense
who felt
like oh i i felt very home there as well
um
and
i i felt inspired by the end of that
project i kind of told everyone like i
need to go back to the us and tell
my own story somehow
i remember that that experience
inspiring me because they were kept on
talking about we want to tell our
stories we want to
um
you know we we just want more chances to
tell our stories so i
made a decision when i left that i'm
going to try to help them tell their own
stories and then i'm going to try to do
tell my own story like there's some some
value in that
um it took me many years to kind of come
around
to doing that though um in a weird way
um
but i
as far as like how i look at what i'll
do in the future
um i'm just kind of interested in doing
everything in a way like i don't i'm not
seeing
any limitation in that regard
i'm not i'm not like a systems guy where
i think systematically about things so i
just kind of feel things out and i'm
just going to feel out if something
feels right or not and do it
and that's probably what will
drive me in the future
and then what i also notice is that i do
the thing like i make something and then
i get really good at talking about it in
hindsight
and i don't know if anyone else relates
to that and i kind of wonder if that's
happened with this film a little bit
because so much of this film was
intuition to be honest um and then only
later do i pick up on some of the
patterns and
um different things that i was thinking
about or influenced by
and then i'm able to talk about it um so
i i don't like to go into something with
the concept in mind first i'd rather
work heavily on the intuitive side and
then
be able to figure out what is this thing
as
afterwards in some way
thank you
all right abraham abbatel forgive me if
i pronounce your name
that was exactly right thank you so much
um hello uh
hello lee isaac i um i really
it's a pleasure to um to meet you
um
i i guess
my main question for you
is um
uh
when you were in the early stages of
your career
um what was
the one thing that you wish
someone had told you
oh thanks abraham um
early stage of my
career
um
i have a lot of these which i don't some
sometimes they're
not
as helpful as others i i think you you
might be asking this though because
you kind of wonder with your own career
and you're kind of wondering
um
what to do and and how your story might
align with mine and what you could
piece from that and
that's it's just my heart goes out to
you it's such a difficult process with
this with with going into film because
it's not an easy path and
it seems as though
so much of this happens to you like you
just happen to be in the right place at
the right time
so there's a lot of that
i would say the the one thing i think
janet alluded to this so beautifully
is that there's a principle to why we're
doing this thing that we do
that
can often be a guide like a belief in
why we're doing it and i think
that is what helps make this path
more
um
it makes it easier and it makes it less
fraught with
disappointment is if you're if you're
working with certain principles of like
wanting to connect
with people or or you know
do something good for your humanity for
society things like that if you're
working with these principles
and you're you're chipping away at it i
think that's always going to be
rewarding and it's always going to be
the right thing to be doing
um and it's the career type of stuff
that is really
um
tricky like it can it can help you get
lost a little bit when you put career
success and all that before
the the stuff that might actually get
you there and the stuff that might get
you there is actually i feel
your inner life and your your principles
and things like that um i don't know if
that answers the question at all but
that's amazing thank you yeah thanks
avery yeah
uh byron hamill
hi
oh there i am
sorry uh so first of all i'm really
excited to meet you and that's probably
why i'm pressing the wrong buttons uh
this this is such a great film and um
it's i i thought it was one of the best
uh family dramas i've i've ever seen but
i i wanted to ask about a a poetic thing
that happens in it when uh david first
when he cuddles his grandma you know and
she the next day she's
starting to get uh sick and and he
starts to heal how much of that was
intuition
and how much of that was something that
you designed
poetically yeah thank you byron um
i yeah that was some uh that was an idea
i had pretty early on that there's going
to be a switch-off where we see
um
david's journey he's kind of going up in
his health and then um soon as she's
going down so at one point there's going
to be an intersection
for those two so i was very much
thinking about that moment when when it
would happen
and i felt like it should happen at a
moment that is very dark for david when
he's really
thinking about death
i don't know why but when i was a kid i
thought about death a lot and and
it would stress my mom out because she
she thought there's no way a kid your
age should be talking about death so
much
i guess i meant you know i was going to
become an artist or something but
that was
so i just thought about that memory
because that was in my list and i
thought i think this is where the inner
section should happen with with her
and that was that was the hardest scene
to shoot i i never had a conversation
like that with my grandma that never
really happened
but there was something about filming
that and
watching yo john tapping david's
shoulder
i every time i watched her do that i
would lose it
um and i just kept feeling like that was
my grandma doing that to me in that
moment
and i i was i couldn't get through it
and
like lockheed
my dp would like hand me tissues and
he'd ask me are you okay do you do you
do you want to move on like we do
something else and
we had our schedule we were shooting so
quickly i said no we got to do this but
you know the sound guys are like we're
hearing the sniffling can you please
uh calm down a little bit
it was just a tough day i can't remember
any other scene that was so hard for me
to get through than that one um and even
now like i watch it and i think i wish i
could have
could try it a little bit more because i
think i could have made that scene a
little better but i was so
you know i was watching that scene
through
blurry eyes it was
yeah
i i i don't think it could have been
better for for what it's worth i think
it's one of the greatest things oh thank
you so much thank you for that i was i
was not fishing for that byron but i'll
take it no but i i did have one more i
know i don't want to take up everyone's
time but did you give your real
grandmother your mountain dew that's my
last question i did not no i did not for
the record i did not and uh
yeah i hope that ends up on a wikipedia
page some days
you can see people clearly love this
film we've studied it very closely
um all right adam bonsuit next please
oh hello hi hi hey adam
so i'm actually not adam i'm alexis
brown i'm using
my work computer so i apologize for that
okay but i really really admire your
work and i think it was an incredible
movie
and i had a question about kind of like
your process and when you were writing
and you said that you wrote 80 memories
and
and they were like very bitter for you
from your childhood
so
with those memories and the characters
that you created what was your process
and coming up with the timeline that
kind of pieced everything together
yeah um
thanks i i i wrote those memories down
on
um
[Music]
yeah so i wrote them on an excel
spreadsheet i'm always like why do i
tell people this but i
i did i did on an excel spreadsheet and
i i had them so that i on on different
cells so that i could cut and paste them
and what i did was i took the memories
and i kind of um put them into
separated them into the different
characters
and so once i had that like each
character has like a set of memories
associated with them
um i would look at is there an arc that
i could tell of each of these characters
stories um and not every memory ended up
in the film like i i definitely whittled
it down quite a lot
um but i definitely started with the
memories and then moved directly into
character that's that's kind of where
the heart of it is for me and um you
know i try to map out their whole lives
i look at if this film is taking place
in 1982 then what
what was happening when they were born
what did they live through like i go
through that i have
multiple tabs in my expel
excel spreadsheet where i kind of like
put out their timelines and
um
yeah so so that's kind of where the
process is it's heavy on the character
side
thank you so much
thank you that's a beautiful answer uh
you're you're combining a little bit of
your earlier science training i guess
excel sheets and tabs yeah very very
organized and structured but also very
very useful
moon question please oh hi um first of
all thank you for giving us like great
inspiration and stories during the
discussion
um
i'm i'm an international student from
korea and i've been living alone here in
the united states for nine months
with this dream of film
so
actually i saw this movie on my first
flight from korea to the united states
so it reminded me of my family a lot and
what i want to ask is how how i can
express my sincere gratitude to my
family
because i'm
recently i'm only immersed in my sadness
so i think i forgot how to say thank you
to my family so
yeah this is my question
um thank you for that
um that's that's so sweet i i hope
i mean the fact that you're asking that
question i think is is going to lead you
to the answer that's that's personal to
you um and
um you know your family much better than
i do so i
um i trust that's that's just the
that's something you'll be doing
all your life trying to find
how best to thank them because
um
i'm trying to learn that too with with
my own family how do i thank them how do
i show gratitude
um and it's not always easy
um
but i'm i'm glad to hear like what
you're what you're up to like i feel
like
a lot of
people who have experienced displacement
and have moved to other cultures
um they make very interesting work like
that there are a lot of filmmakers like
that you know ang lee was a film student
in new york for instance from taiwan
um and you know you can just see his
perspective on life it's it's it's not
it's it's different and it's but it's
very beautiful
um and so there are many examples of
filmmakers who have just lived in
different places and who
are able to tell a more
i
i
even dare say like a more universal
story as a result so
um
yeah
all right
much courage to you i i hope um
i hope your studies go well
thank you thank you for answering this
lovely answer uh emery tana titi please
ah thank you for pronouncing my name
very accurately
yes
hi um i'm emory i'm also international
except i'm past the student part of it
and trying to make a film making career
in um
america and so i
i was suddenly nervous but i minari is
my favorite movie ever i think when i
first watched it i cried so much because
um really reminded me of my grandmother
when she brought
the things back from korea to home
um from thailand and hong kong so my
grandmother would bring stuff from hong
kong back for us
um
and uh i think it really inspired me to
because this is exactly the kind of
movie i've been wanting to create my
whole life like something that's about
family
about culture and i just saw in one and
so like first time just really thank you
for like letting me see that like this
could totally be a reality
and um i guess the question i have for
you is as a director um one of the
things that everybody talks about in the
movie it's like how well the pacing was
and for me like a lot of the arguments
were really real they i've experienced
these growing up and the pacing for that
for what they say on the screen and what
they don't say everything emotion like
in emotions were like just done so well
how do you go about directing that
uh thanks
yeah first of all thank you emory that
that's
uh incredibly touching um
and
um
for the pacing of of the film
um that there was a lot that was
internal with that as i was making the
film
um
when i was editing like i would i would
worry that i didn't do it fast enough
like i um it's funny like on the day
normally when i'm directing like i just
follow my intuition with that stuff
um and then later i figure out um if i
did if i did it right
in the editing room pacing-wise
and so
um
i would say like i i'm never the type of
director who has like a stopwatch you
know that or or looks at like how long
things took just whether or not it felt
right
and we were
going for
um something that felt truthful with
this one more more than like
the energy of the camera movement or
things like that that that are actually
really important in other types of films
but this one was like a
family story very
um very simple so
i was just trying to keep it feeling
real
in a way and then i worked with harry
yoon and when i was editing he was
really a
a compass for me like he would
he kind of had down
the pacing that would work the balance
that would work for this because
um there's something that happens for me
when i watch
something way too much then i start to
wonder like if it's boring if it's
uh if it's not working and for some
reason i was watching like stranger
things and the mandalorian while we were
editing
and i kept thinking we got to go faster
and
luckily harry was like no no we got this
don't worry and uh
harry is like a brother to me after that
experience because he
he um he just kind of kept
he kept me sane and cool with what we
had he kept reassuring me this is good
this is working so
um in other words intuition but you also
need some people to help you that in my
case
thank you so much yeah thank you
okay i see three more hands up and i
think we're gonna have to if it's okay
with you leigh isaac we'll take these
last three questions
okay
uh
all right i'm gonna try niccolo esquivel
zeta
don't worry about the last name it's
such a it's such a difficult thing um
uh what an incredible opportunity thank
you so much uh i'm so grateful for this
um and i just want to comment on how um
your film was just so universal because
i managed to connect uh uh with it even
though i'm not an immigrant from korea
uh i am an immigrant and i thought
that immigrant experience even though it
was korean uh it managed to
relate so much to the general immigrant
ethos which i thought was uh fantastic
um
and uh well i just had one question um
uh in like an increasingly uh
uh secular world uh i noticed that
minari has uh relies on
like huge themes of faith you know and
relying on faith uh so my question is in
an increasingly secular world how do you
how do you manage to incorporate
faith into
uh into the narrative without becoming
um too cheesy or
disingenuous oh thank you nicolo
um
to answer your question yeah i
um
i mean i i
feel
i would say i'm a christian filmmaker
you know i i
christianity and
faith is is quite a big part of my own
life
um
and it was something that i would kind
of shy away from
sometimes
in terms of like what i present because
it's such a loaded sort of topic and it
turns people off and like my
my intention with it is not like to
um proselytize or preach or anything
like that but
um
in this case like this story was so
personal it was so much about like the
things that i think about and the way
that i see things that i just wanted to
be true to it um
and that includes like the very real
doubts and you know um the ways in which
that i i think
i i i make fun of my own self for for
the things that i believe so i you hear
that all in the film as well those
perspectives um that that everybody has
and i think on a spiritual level like
everybody in that film kind of
represents some part of me
my own spiritual walk and journey and
perspective on things you know in many
ways i'm i'm some guy who's like
you know telling
her daughter to stop preaching this
nonsense
um i'm i'm jacob who believes you know
using my own hands and
and uh using my mind and all those
things and then i'm also monica who just
you know wants to pray for people and um
really believes and and um
hopes for for for better things
and even crazy paul i have those sides
with me too
so i was just trying to be honest with
it really exploring every character and
loving them like loving
that part of everybody you know and
really respecting and honoring them and
not criticizing any of them
awesome thank you so much
thank you all right
hey guys what's up hi lee isaac my name
is patricio thank you so much for your
time thank you so much for this insight
it's been really really dope my question
is um
what film do you recommend everybody
should watch i'm currently looking for
something to watch so other than minari
of course other than minority i would
recommend everybody watch
i'm gonna give a shout out to someone
who i i just spent
a few days with this guy and i gotta say
hands down he's one of my favorite
people and it is darius martyr and he
made an incredible film called sound of
metal
sound in the middle of dairy smarter
yeah go watch sound of metal by darius
martyr this guy is the real deal
okay perfect
i think i'm i googled it right now oh
rizzo mad nice
i think it's
an incredible guy too
performance
if you haven't seen it please please
watch perfect all right so much
isaac cows next and i see parvati just
join us so that's absolutely the final
one then no more questions please after
this we have to take a question from yes
yes yeah
hi uh liz isaac um first of all
thank you for being a great filmmaker
with the name isaac big inspiration to
me
um
yeah i'm a taiwanese-american filmmaker
so it's really cool that you mentioned
angli before
i'm also christian so it's really cool
to hear about that for your
own story my question is for your
writing process um
i've read up a little bit on how you
wrote me
and
the whole diving into memories um
and you i think you've mentioned
dostoevsky as inspiration before um so
i'm just wondering
um
yeah just
writing inspirations who you
would recommend reading as well as
your own maybe daily or
usual writing practice
and
if you incorporate the bible into any of
that
um
um thank you isaac um
yeah to be honest i do read the bible
every morning as and it's um i was
talking to another writer minjin lee who
does the same
um it
and there there's a lot of inspiration
in there especially the old testament
which is just filled with such
incredible and crazy stories that um
yeah you could see the influence of it
in in so much
um but i um wondering i
um
one book i really liked recently was
called a swim in the pond in the rain by
george saunders it's a really great book
and i love i love
russian authors so like chekhov was a
huge inspiration in
in
uh for minuti like um
he has a story called the step which was
uh
really wonderful but he breaks down how
to read a story and how to
figure how to
uh how stories are told i think that
book is really invaluable for um writers
um
and it and then on
the question that you asked about
disciplines and practices i think that's
really super important like let's say
you only have
an hour in the day that you can spare to
writing it's kind of like exercise you
only have an hour you can go to the gym
or whatever i feel like it's really
important to um
to
set that hour and be true to it
try to be as consistent as possible and
do a little
do a little something that helps you get
into the writing
ritualistically
so that your body and your mind it knows
that okay i'm entering my writing space
um
i'm normally not this prescriptive about
things but i
for many years i was just the type who
would wait till inspiration struck and
then i would like um sit down and bang
something out and then for many days i
wouldn't do anything
that was never helpful for me
in retrospect i realized like what ended
up working is just sitting down every
day even when nothing's flowing
um
even if it means like you sit down and
you just drink a cup of coffee and
you're not doing anything and you're
writing nonsense and gibberish
like your body just needs to kind of
realize you're in that writing space and
your body starts to help
get into that mode for you automatically
so
this was especially important after i
had my child after my daughter came
around in which i only had a certain
amount of time it was usually like nap
time or something like that in which i
could sit down and do something um and
you'd be amazed by by how much that
little discipline can actually help you
to focus and to work so i would i would
highly suggest that and i see on the
side uh yeah it's a swim in the pond in
the ring that's that's the title of the
book
so thanks for writing that
okay
thank you i'm gonna ask one more
question before i get to parvati because
someone cannot turn her camera and
mike on
and i thought it was an interesting
question so that's an african-american
woman who says that
she noticed that minardi
resonated with so many non-asian people
of color and what do you think
uh resonated particularly with asian
sorry african-american audiences
especially since uh she has roots in the
south
um
when when i was growing up
we we didn't have an african american
community around me it was it was
quite a striking thing and it was
um
it was weird like i i remember
i felt such a deep connection to
african-american music and books and
like it was sudden it was when i would
discover these things it gave me a sense
of
that
particular perspective of someone who is
on the outside in many ways
and i feel like
we often relate there's so many things
that we are are similar
we have similarities
um
very strong families sense of family um
that's multi-generational um there there
are these elements very strong
the the work of women being so strong
and vital um
yeah there are just so many touchstones
that to me was always a deep connection
that i wonder if that's
um that's a source of connection i would
hope um
yeah but i really appreciate that
question
thank you okay last but not least
parvati devi
hi
uh thank you so much for joining us and
also uh i just want to say that
everything you've been speaking about
with your
uh experience with filmmaking has been
really relatable which is really
refreshing to hear oh thanks barbara
yeah i wanted to ask because uh minari
was such a personal story for you to
tell i think it's really easy for
filmmakers to like when telling a
personal story they want full control
over every single aspect of the
filmmaking process so they want to have
full control over the editing the way
that the actors act i wanted to ask what
is your mindset when it comes to
trusting um
the different people to do their thing
and to fulfill their own roles while
also
being satisfied with your own filmmaking
um
there's definitely
uh
such a big part of filmmaking that
should i feel surrender and yield
to
the creative process for me that
creative process is
that filmmaking is a collaborative art
form and
sometimes we
filmmakers get into the trap of thinking
that that is a threat to our vision but
i view that i view what we do as being
an incredible opportunity and pos
is something that allows us to achieve
something that is impossible on our own
um so
case in point uh
when when we're making minari um
i
i wanted i had a stupid idea i'll put it
that way that that's the way i lead it i
had some stupid idea about the
production design
and i got into a slight like argument
with young oakley our production
designer about it and
and then finally i threw down my my uh
my card i was like
um this is this is the way it was in my
family so let's just do it this way
and and then young said this is not your
family she like yelled at me but this is
not your family this is the e family and
and she was kind of saying like this
family belongs as much to her as it does
to me
and and then she told me you know this
is this is why this is personal to me
um
for me that was that was kind of
mind-blowing it put me in my place where
i i realized everybody has ownership in
this project everybody is bringing
something personal to it and because
because of that it's growing into
something that's so much bigger than
this you know this small brain you know
it's it becomes something much bigger
um and everybody was bringing stuff like
that like our lighting guy um was was a
white man from
from arkansas who now lives in oklahoma
and
um
he he's an incredible guy steve mathis
he was he told me you know i took on
this project because i also lived in a
trailer home with my grandma my grandma
kind of raised me in the ozarks
and um and he with his lighting there's
something so deeply personal about how
he lit that mobile home
um in a very respect
respectful dignified humanizing way
that could only come from him in in a
way that
you know comes from his memories all
these different things that are just so
beautiful you know
um so so that's kind of the process that
i'm still learning as i go because
inevitably i always think
um when you're prepping something you
get worried so you want to control it
you want and you figure out this is
exactly how we're going to execute the
thing but
on the day when you're filming it's
those people around you who really save
the day and and show you better ideas so
that's that's part of the work of being
a director i think is to recognize that
and especially when you're making a
personal film where
you can sometimes be blinded by by how
personal it is to you and how close it
is to you the other people help get you
out of your head you know um because
sometimes when it's so close to you it's
hard to communicate those things but
other people will will help
help you bring those things out in the
right way
hope that answers the question yes thank
you that's really um that's something i
will remember always like it's as much
your film as it is the other people who
are working on it exactly yeah
yeah you know there's nothing more
rewarding than when you finish something
and uh
finish a film and everybody feels like
they own part of it like
yeah that is
that's just beautiful um that's exactly
what you wanted to feel like
that is thank you so much
i think that's why we
do what we do in in some measure you
know the process of creating something
together and then having that result be
shared with others that we may not even
know
but somehow there's a connection made
lee isaac chung it has been such a
pleasure to talk to you you really share
yourself so genuinely and generously
and vulnerably and i'm sure everyone
listening now and listening later on
youtube
will really
embrace so much of what you said
so thank you thank you and i want to
give a special thanks to your wife and
child for comforting you in that
moment when you thought you might give
up and also to your parents and
grandparents and everyone else who's
made a life that was so rich for you to
mine
in this most beautiful movie ninari
thank you for participating in the
academy's visiting artists series